[Music]  uncle casey can't just stay for one  night  one night  [Music]  really  how big is he gonna get that depends on  how much you love him  clifford how did this happen  [Music]  that's the big red dog so cute  you know i'm a little better why don't  you take his temperature where in the  animal temperature taking place  [Music]  how has he not popped that yet  there we are  it's all over the internet there's a 10  foot dog in upper manhattan that can't  be real we are offering a 25 000 reward  for the capture of the big red dog  people don't like things that are  different  there are no other dogs like you what's  he doing i think he's trying to be  small room full  [Music]  what if you found someone who was so  full of love  your dog just saved my life  i'm getting clifford out of here you  know how to drive how hard can it be  i'm grounded for life aren't i you and  me both  he eats like an animal he's an animal  i'm talking about him  what  [Music]